new tactics and new equipment for the
protesters as the crackdown from myanmar
security forces
escalates
but despite this wednesday's protests
again turned deadly
with live ammunition being used along
with rubber bullets and stun grenades
the protesters now wear helmets use
homemade shield and even create smoke
screens themselves
to hide from snipers and gunmen but when
the smoke clears the protest barriers
their line of defense
are gone in mandalay a regular scene for
gatherings during the month of protests
they have also increased their
protection against the police and
military
but even with the added measures there's
little they can do against live rounds
and in the southern city of daway the
red flag of onsongsu's nld party was
hoisted images
of the military leader min onglai pasted
on the ground
as the protest continued on wednesday
ousted president winman will face two
additional charges
his lawyer describing what it could mean
shall be punished
with imprisonment of either description
for a time which may extend to three
years
or with fine or with both
some feel that the charges against when
men and aung tsuchi are trumped up
possibly to prevent them from ever
returning to politics
despite women being detained since one
february he's only now just had access
to his lawyers
and his lawyers haven't even received a
copy of the charge seat or the case file
so these are fundamental fair repair
trial rights
violations that are taking place on top
of everything else
so as the protesters continue their
stand against the coup on the streets
across myanmar their elected leaders are
facing their own battle
in a judicial system that appears to be
working against them
scott heidler al jazeera